here to respond tulsi gabby former
hawaii congresswoman and a former
presidential candidate uh congresswoman
thank you so much for joining us tonight
um you know i've been following you on
twitter and some of your public comments
part of the most
the most concerning thing that i've been
seeing from the media is that they don't
remember that time apparently or they
have amnesia
people didn't feel safe
and i'm not advocating for vigilante
justice but when government
doesn't do its job people step up to
protect themselves
uh that that's exactly right and and i i
don't i would not assume that uh they
have amnesia because when you think back
to that time we remember very clearly
that
immediately after this incident this
tragedy occurred with kyle rittenhouse
the mainstream media pro-antifa
politicians were very quick to say this
kid is a white supremacist terrorist uh
and so even at that time in the midst of
all of that chaos there was no interest
in saying hey you know what this is a
tragedy that the crisis that the city is
facing is is a tragedy let's actually
wait and follow the evidence and and let
this work itself through our judicial
system uh the government absolutely
failed to fulfill this most basic
responsibility of keeping their
community safe kyle rittenhouse
shouldn't have gone and done what he did
but as you said you know he's a foolish
kid who uh like others in the community
felt like they had no other choice but
to step up and to try to do their part
to keep people safe you know
congresswoman i have a problem with the
inconsistency that i see from the left
and people that claim to be civil
libertarians that wanted to fight for
the rights of the people if you agree
that the state should have the knee on
someone's neck and kill them then how
could you support the state
intentionally targeting a young man that
it shows in the video that is
self-defense it shows on the witness
stand their own prosecution's witness
admitted that he aimed his gun at him
first
this is this is the problem here right
is that there is no care or interest in
evidence or the facts or justice really
it's about politics it's about hey are
you one of us are you one of them are
you on our team or are you the quote
unquote enemy and as we've seen in this
example and others if you're not on our
team then you are a racist you're a
white supremacist you're a terrorist and
they levy out these allegations really
without care again for the evidence
facts or the consequences and we're
seeing the same thing happening here uh
with the judge in this trial because of
his ringtone
being a patriotic song god blessed the
usa
obviously they're saying hey he's he's
biased towards kyle rittenhouse uh so so
what conclusion are we to draw from that
that if you love america then you are a
white supremacist uh this is the
craziness of what we're seeing play out
here which really for me you know it
shows
that they hate america that they have
such disdain for those who love america
that this is the allegation that they
threw out and it's especially offensive
as we sit here on veterans day uh this
disdain extends to those who wear or
worn the uniform who are willing to
sacrifice their lives to serve our
country it's extremely offensive and
they should be ashamed of themselves
they should but they're not because they
want to take down
political opponents that that is exactly
what this is about and it's sad
congresswoman thank you for your honesty
here tonight on the program
i hope you come back hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else